hello there I'm gav I'm Dan we're the
slomo guys a lot of the time people send
us clips of other people's slo-mo and
they want us to recreate it but to be
honest most the time they've nailed it
already I mean there's no need for us to
just reshoot the same thing but I
thought what if we take something in
just slightly escalate it so I've seen
videos before where there's a tennis
racket covered in powder paint and
tennis ball hits it and leaves behind
the perfect shape of the tennis racket
in powder paint yeah that sort of tennis
racket the solid part drops away and all
of the the particulates just remain
lingering in the air yeah I've seen the
same thing with like a net with water on
it and things like that where something
hits it and it just leaves behind the
perfect water so I thought instead of a
tennis racket we could use this
trampoline that would make me the ball
it would make you the ball okay I'll try
and do my best impression of a tennis
ball and hopefully we'll leave my
perfect sort of outline in powder paint
be quite a very similar effect to what
we saw with the mouse traps but
more colorful and less painful and less
painful and less time to set up
let's do it so we'll quickly replicate
this one that's red I think this one
will end up looking like something out
of a artsy music video a lot of our
stuff ends up looking like that
and a lot of our stuff that we do ends
up being in music videos it's true it's
one of my favorites this is such a nice
color
it's so rich right now I've got to be
really careful not to move it too much
yeah today we're filming uh a thousand
frames a second in 4k if you've got a
lovely new 4K TV maybe bun this one on
it so you're going to be in charge of
quite a lot basically everything here
okay here we go
it's gone miles
that's a good lob was it yeah pretty
good yeah it was solid the tennis racket
flung around and twatted my leg oh sorry
I was wondering what that second sound
was ready yep
lovely cool each of the different colors
is it behaves differently but it's
different weights though isn't it yeah
the red is a bit more clumpy than the
orange yeah there's like two clumpy ones
at either side in the middle and the
rest are quite powdery
[Music]
I love the wind tucking all this stuff
in the middle it's cool you can see the
tennis racket vibrating
oh yeah good luck cheers so you've got
yourself a little injury B yeah it's
gonna be popping in in and out of this
video and some other videos and some
other videos I think we did a little
practice run of the main part of this
video just to make sure uh you know with
lighting and angles and stuff to
practice my jump anything you forgot to
do mid jump yeah well I was
concentrating so hard on getting in the
right spot that I forgot to turn my face
to the side so I just went fish beamed
head first into the trampoline and uh I
like must have landed face first and
slid a little bit it's like scratched my
nose off I think if I'd had done it I
would have gone straight through I would
have cut a hole through the trampoline
yeah he's just gone
all right it looks like I've just caught
you committing a crime you pretty much
have the thing is I don't want to mess
this up and because once it's done it's
like
oh it's done yeah this is the last time
there won't be paint everywhere yeah on
this trampoline Okay so here we go I'm
pouring oh
if I pull the thing onto there
that is so immensely fine
it's going everywhere
it's so light that a lot of it is just
taking to the air we'll find all this
over here originally slipping around
don't breathe yeah yeah we'll give you a
paint mask when you do it yeah
absolutely otherwise it will go all of
my nose and everything
oh gosh
really sensitive
I think my favorite part is your face
while you're doing it
okay
oh
look at that in the air
it looks like the Grinch just got blown
up
[Music]
foreign
don't sneeze don't sneeze don't light a
match look both cameras triggers coming
into a little t-junction now all the
pressure's on me to just put my face
and exactly the right spot for the focus
otherwise it's a redo
yeah I'd say on the crease between red
and orange on that plane yeah that'd be
pretty good
good luck
this is going to fill the room with
particles
probably all right ready yeah
oh
flipping oh heck
[Laughter]
I like went to another dimension
like I I I jumped I saw it coming
towards me right and I was like I've got
the aim right I nailed it I think and I
just turned my head I probably blinked
but then when I opened my eyes
I just like been taking a smack in the
face and I ended up in like this big
cloud of like colors oh look that you
got like purple knee bloony green shorts
yellow shirt orange face and red hair
it's like perfectly
so just try and get into a cab like this
like what oh look at what it's done to
the place oh
red over here
and purple over here
oh no here we go
oh my hand coming in
whoa oh
God I just like disappeared in a cloud
it's just like
my legs are just dangling out the rest
of me it looks like I'm coming out of a
nebula in space that's wild that is look
at look at the hand alone perfect that's
so cool like trampoline is just gone you
can see it Ripple back like you see that
that shock wave coming from your hand
yeah you could see a shock wave and then
the rest of my Chunky body like lands in
your head is just from the forehead up
is in the red
look right you said to aim between the
red and the orange my eyes were on the
red and the orange border if you look it
couldn't have been more perfect
and then you just erupt out but you were
fired backwards out of a cannon I'm just
carrying some with me still look I clear
the frame look now what you don't see
that I saw with my eyes is that I think
because of the way we've got the bag all
of the air that was under the trampoline
was compressed and there was no effort
to go other than out of the spring holes
so you went in and then all of this
color from all around just went it was
like it was like a vent you don't
actually really see it on it I hope I
hope we see it on this one so this is
the wide it will get me coming in a lot
sooner oh there's my hand but
[Music]
one dive
oh
I just disappeared
and see all the vortices coming out that
is
wow and the the backlight is awesome
essentially the ceiling light doubling
is a backlight but I absolutely flew out
of there as well
you're just coming back to the top of
three from like there was a frame there
when I was clean all right look you're
opening your eyes
you briefly just were like just survey
the situation
I'll tell you what
no spoilers but I couldn't see much
I just like the idea of being at the
Apex and being like Yep this is going
well straight back down look you can see
your legs back there in the backlight
it looks like a storm
it looks like uh like [ __ ] oh yeah
you know just [ __ ] your legs
just looks like a wall you know like how
a wolf like goes in the work in front of
the Moon yeah
what's going on but you're just in the
air I'm poking through the clouds
that is a bizarre sight it's honestly
like you've you fell down as Dan Grocery
and you came back as Markiplier the
Markiplier
well
for not
foreign
once again I feel like that was very
reminiscent of our drum video yeah it
was but it was
sorry you just I was just laughing at
what you did there we just made a hell
of a mess with absolutely no time at all
but honestly it is an absolute disaster
Zone here we might need an extra day
just to clean
I like how you said we there oh yeah
I'll be I'll be cleaning the equipment
oh the equipment yeah yeah I'll be
cleaning all of this like honestly look
at this it's absolutely caked I don't
know what we expected I also love how we
actually put this little bag sort of
tarpaulin underneath the trampoline in
an effort to catch the paint because I
thought you know put the paint on it
it's all going to go through we can just
take that
we just made a paint Cannon this made it
way worse it blasted all the air up yeah
firing all the spilled paint into the
air but an unintended extremely visually
cool set of vortices on each color
go back but just delete that a little
bit 10 seconds
oh did you like how I did the the tram
you know brilliant idea it's a textbook
idea you've thought ahead and it worked
out yeah hopefully you enjoyed that
video make sure you subscribe if you
like listening to us lying fools and
we'll see you in the next video thank
you very much for watching I'm gonna
have a shower yeah I'm gonna
I don't even know where to start